Hey, man, that
right there ain’t supposed to be like that.
My elbows?
That shouldn't be
I’m double jointed.
Yeah.
That shouldn’t be like that.
It helps swimming.
Look like it hurt,
didn't it?
What, like,
ultimately brought you to Phoenix?
Like, what made you
Bob
My coach
Really?
Yeah.
I mean, just because he,
so I was finishing my career.
I had, like, two years, a year
and a half left in my career,
and he goes, “I'm going to take the head
coaching job at ASU. Would you come?”
and I was like, “Yeah, sure, why not?”
For me, seeing the sunshine
every day is wonders.
Just make you feel good.
Yeah.
Like you can wake up
and feel absolutely terrible
and just go outside and stand in the sun
and get some nice vitamin D
and you feel like a different person, so
here we are five years later.
The rest is history.
Phelps, what’s happening?
You alright?
Yeah, can’t complain.
Man, appreciate you being here.
First and foremost, I thought we'd
do it here because we both love golf.
We played golf a few times.
I won’t talk about how bad I done beat him
[laughing]
but, you know,
to start it off,
just a little bit about yourself
and, you know, where you’re from, Baltimore.
Born and raised in Baltimore, Maryland.
The youngest of three.
Baby boy.
The only boy.
I played baseball, lacrosse, soccer,
and swam
till I was 11 years old
and then decided to focus on swimming.
Only because my coach told me
I could make the Olympic team.
And then everything kind of took off.
But did somebody swim, like, around
you at like, I know your mom?
Yeah.
So, we, so my sisters both swam.
Whitney,
my middle sister, was internationally,
what? Number three in the world?
Number one in the nation at 15.
Or 13, excuse me.
Swimming?
Swimming.
I never knew that.
And then I
saw her just doing all these cool things
and I was like, I want to do that.
Like, I want to go to Rome and swim
there and go to world championships
and have a chance to go to the Olympics.
So at the age of 11, my coach sat down
with myself, my parents, and was like,
“You have an opportunity to do
something really special in four years”
“if.” And I was like, “Okay, what?”
If what?
No other sports, you're
dropping the other sports.
So I was focused on swimming
and that was it.
So as an 11 year old kid, I heard the word
Olympics and I was all in.
That was it.
That young, at 11?
Yeah.
Just having the opportunity
to represent your country,
win an Olympic gold medal. Like for me,
I wanted to break a world record, and
the only route to be able to have that
chance was swimming at the highest level.
What was it like then, though?
Like, what was the preparation
like at 11
for like swimming? Was you like swimming
before school, swimming after school?
I mean, back then I was
probably only swimming a handful of times
a week, maybe five days a week.
But you was always that nice?
Uhhh, probably not.
I think I got better
and better pretty quick.
So when you was in high school, right, like,
I was never caught near a pool, right?
Like I taught myself how to swim on a AAU trip
just because I was scared.
I was scared.
You would get in the pool,
everybody would be playing around.
And, you know, especially
in Black households, somebody even thought
about pushing you in the pool
it was going to start a fight.
[laughing]
It was going to start a fight.
So when you were in high school and stuff,
were your meets, like, not even close?
Like, when did you start
knowing, like, “Okay, I'm”
“I'm nice”?
I was breaking national age group records
from the age of eight on, like,
I mean, I probably broke 200 national age
group records. So national age group
records are the fastest time swam
in that age group.
So I was 15, 16 breaking the open records.
So as a 16 year old or 15 year old,
I made my first Olympic team.
Um, yeah, that's different.
That's very different.
And so let's talk for a second
about that type of spotlight.
Like, what was that like?
I was a deer in headlights
in my first Olympics,
a 15 year old kid,
never traveled outside of the country.
I'm here standing an Olympic final
All I wanted to do was get one second
faster than I did at trials.
I got 90, 98, 96/100ths faster
and I was less than three tenths
out of a second from a medal,
and I wanted a medal.
And that motivation from,
from not medaling catapulted me into 2004.
I say
I fall short
in 2004 because I wasn't perfect, right?
I lost.
I don't like to lose.
We don't like to lose.
So
Yeah, exactly.
So I use that motivation to then
catapult me into 2008 to where
we had all the tools that we needed
at that point
to be able to compete at that level
at every single race.
During that week in Beijing
I think I swam 60,000 meters.
So during a regular training week
I was swimming 80 to 100,000 meters.
So because of all the warm ups,
warm downs, this, that, and the other,
I had to be extremely prepared.
And that week took eight years
to get prepared for. I had to swim
that event program
over and over and over again.
So in '08, I didn't see anything else.
I was like, almost like a racehorse
with blinders on.
Right.
You was just so locked in
—I knew exactly what I had to do.
I knew like to the second, I knew where
I had to be at every, every single day.
What was the crazy thing
everybody used to talk about, how
many calories or something you used to have to eat?
What was it?
So I was eating eight to 10,000 calories
every day because when we're swimming,
I can fluctuate
between five and ten pounds in a week.
And when we're trying to be at our best,
we want to be at race weight at all times.
So I'm forcing myself to eat.
I don't like to eat now.
Like, I can't stand to eat.
I eat what I need to, to
When you say eight
—give my body what it needs.
You said eight to 10,000 calories a day.
What's that look like?
Whatever.
Literally whatever, because you can't eat
all good foods and get that many calories.
Right.
So I'm mixing a pint of ice cream
or milkshakes or cookies or like,
I mean a breakfast would have been,
you know,
two breakfast sandwiches, a bowl of grits,
an omelet, short
stack of chocolate chip pancakes.
And then I'd go take a nap
and then I'd wake up, have,
I don't know, a bagel
and a PowerBar or a bagel and some fruit.
–If I do that, I’m gonna blow up
–swim for another two hours.
If I do that, I'm gonna blow up.
I'm gonna blow up. That is out.
I cannot do that.
—But
I mean, I had to maintain that weight.
So I mean, but and the crazy thing
now, like, I think back to it,
I think the reason why I don't like to eat
is because there are always people over
my shoulder being like,
“You're not eating enough.”
Like, “You got to put food into your system,”
you know, 30 minutes
after a workout, right? Like,
–You’re a machine
–Yes
And that's what it, that's what it felt like.
So for me, I'm like, no, I just
I want to eat when I want to eat,
what I want to eat.
If I say this name to you, Bob Bowman,
right?
That’s a coach that you're still close with.
In what I've done over the years,
whether it be football or basketball,
I've had a ton of different coaches.
What is it like to have that relationship
with someone for a long time?
He’s a dad, like,
I didn't
I didn't always have a dad growing up.
So for me, having somebody there that was
one: believed in you
had confidence in you,
but also helped you along the way.
I learned a lot from him
and I still learn a lot from him.
He's somebody that comes to the house
almost every day.
He's grandpa to the boys.
Still?
Still
–Yep
So he's coaching here at ASU
and yeah, he's in the pool
with the boys when the weather's nice
and he’s just grandpa.
There were many times
when you contemplated
like retiring, retiring.
Why didn't you?
You ain't got–
not just because me and Frank told
you not to,
but, but why?
Why didn't you?
The fuel that was inside of me.
I mean, for me,
like, in 2012 when I retired,
it was, it was,
it was more of a break than anything else,
you know, because for so long
my head was staring at a black line
and I couldn't do anything else.
I was never a kid.
And so I wanted to find out
what being a kid was like
So I think at that point, for me
to have that kind of growing up process
and seeing a little bit on my own,
learning a little bit on my own, like,
I just couldn't walk away.
I didn't want to walk away.
But the time was right
for me to walk away when I did. And
that didn't
answer your question at all, but
Oh, it did.
I'm over here just
thinking about how the fact that I got,
I got two Olympic gold medals
and I thought I had done,
I'd done something, right?
You sitting over there with 23 gold medals.
Like which one
is sort of like the most important,
is the one where you won by a point?
Yeah.
I mean, honestly, from a textbook
like best performance,
I would say
it's probably the 200 free from Beijing.
Yeah and I think that my favorite
besides that has to be the four-peat.
To win the same event
over four straight Olympics.
Like that's kind of crazy to think about.
I think I could see it in your face too,
like in '16, right, because
you sort of the old guy
You know what I mean?
–I was the dad of the team.
Right, right. Basically.
And I know you, how competitive you are,
and so probably one of the best feelings is
doing what everybody thinks that you can't, right?
How was that?
I mean, I have–my whole career was filled
with people who doubted me.
Um, you know, going into 2008
Thorpe said I'd never win
eight gold medals, but
Thank you, Ian
And he knows, he knows
that was, I think he said
afterwards, he goes, “I know how you work
and I know how to motivate you”
To go from that spotlight year in
and year out to retirement,
what was that like?
Um,
it's weird
Going from
basically every single day
is scheduled, perfect–
Like, you don't have to think, right?
You get up, you go to practice, you do this,
you eat, you do this, you fall asleep
you go back to practice, you ice tub, massage,
I still can’t imagine
–eat, go back to sleep, like
all this stuff
I mean, I did it all for 20 years
straight.
So like, you take that away,
I feel like a kid.
I don't know what I'm doing.
So for me, like having three kids now,
I've learned as they've learned,
because my childhood was swimming.
Mm-hmm.
And that was it.
So I'm learning through this process of
trying to fulfill my day
with things that make me, me
and make me the best me.
Right.
You showed a lot of courage
to speak about mental health
and talk about the things
that you've dealt with in life.
What finally gave you
that courage and wanted you to
talk about it
and share it? Because we all deal with it.
I think it's just a lot of times,
you know, people don't talk about it.
It's crazy.
I go back and
it was 2014.
Sports Illustrated cover story
with Tim Layden and
we're having an interview here
in Phoenix and
whatever question he asked me
just opened me up,
dropped my shoulders
and I just let it all out
I was just ready to, you know.
I think for me when I checked myself
in to get treatment and to get help,
I knew that that's what I needed
and I was at the end of the road
and I had to get help.
I was at a scary place and time,
and for a long time,
I didn't know how to ask for help.
I think once I asked help for the first
time, everything became easy.
So that question, when he asked me
or whatever it was, it just opened me up
and I felt comfortable
to share everything that I'd been through
because it was almost like I said
to myself, “I don't care what people think.”
“This is me and this is my journey
and it makes me who I am.”
So you know, the only way
for me to learn and grow and to get over
certain things that I've gone through
is to communicate and to talk about it.
And look, I'm not perfect, right?
Like, nobody's perfect.
And I struggled a lot through my life.
My first depression spell
was in 2004,
and I went up and down rollercoasters
all throughout life.
Like we all do.
And I think the coolest part about it is
not that you do it for that reason at all,
because you're doing it for yourself,
but you just speaking about it.
It just gave so many other people
a lot more courage, not just athletes,
just people in general.
Why you think so many people
are having a hard time admitting
to grappling
with, like, these mental issues and...?
I think it's vulnerability.
I think vulnerability is a scary word
for a lot of people,
and it's a scary word for me.
I remember when I checked
into a treatment center, I was shaking
when I went in there because I didn't know
what I'm getting myself into, but
I wanted help.
I didn't like feeling the way that I did.
So what else is out there?
I started asking questions.
And look, you know, for me
as a male athlete, I thought like, I–
I couldn't talk about it.
Right, like you almost–
You're giving away weaknesses
–weakness, right
Yeah, like you're giving away
something to your competitors.
And, you know, that's hard to do
when you're in this field of battle.
So, you know, my approach now is if we're
physically strong and mentally strong.
Oh, wow.
You put those things together.
–Yeah.
–We’re unstoppable.
–Unstoppable.
So you now live here in Phoenix,
this beautiful weather,
your amazing wife, Nicole.
You have three beautiful kids, all boys.
You once said that “she's seen the good,
the bad, and the ugly.”
What do you mean by that?
Yeah, you know,
I mean, she's seen me as, you know,
an Olympic champion.
Me as a dad,
me depressed, me feeling like
the worst person on the planet.
Like, she's seen all of it.
She's seen every single side of me.
And look, I can sit here and talk about it
because it's who I am,
and I love who I am.
It's taken a long time for me
to look in the mirror and like who I am.
So for me, like,
I'll say the hardest thing was going
through the pandemic.
Being able to understand and manage my emotions
through the pandemic was overwhelming.
Right.
Like, some of the scariest moments
of my life, and without my wife there,
I don't know if I'd be here today.
Yeah, the Covid pandemic has been called
a mental health crisis.
Obviously I went to the bubble.
People are still dealing with it,
especially kids.
Especially children, right?
Like, kids being at home school,
doing everything on a computer and Zoom.
What’s something that you think can help
these kids
that are facing these
different challenges?
Loneliness has struck us
more than anything, in my opinion,
over the last two years.
And loneliness leads to depression,
which leads to other things.
So for me it's trying to do whatever you can
to have normalcy in your life.
Like, what does that look like?
You know, like, I have no idea. Like,
you know what you do, right?
Like, for me, I have three kids,
two of them are at school.
I mean, I play golf. I sit at home.
–Trust me, I know
–I work from home.
I don't travel anymore. Like, you know?
I live here,
my family is in L.A., so I get it.
It's hard, but it's like,
I think trying to find a routine,
some kind of routine,
I think is always important.
And as athletes, it's something that we know
and we do every single day of our life,
but finding
some kind of normal routine,
because then you get to feel like you.
Because the moment you start feeling
not yourself, you start spiraling.
So I think finding ways to be
your authentic self
is something that's so important.
So self-care, right?
I work out every day,
six, seven days a week.
That's something I have to do for me.
I go and hit golf balls once or twice
a week, put headsets in, and I just hit
golf balls like I'm in my own world
and sometimes I go swim.
But I need that
in order to be the best dad that I can,
to be the best husband that I can.
So, you know,
we want to give ourselves a chance.
So how can we give ourselves
a chance?
Yeah, let’s, uh–
Let’s hit this range and see what the, see
what that swing looking like these days.
I like it.
Yeah.
You know, something I always wanted
to ask you, which is,
I mean, you're used to it, but it seemed like
it would be kind of weird to me, right?
So in some of your meets or races,
you have teammates, right?
–Yeah.
Like, you have teammates.
But then you may do a meet where
the person who was just your teammate
–Mm-hmm
–You going against them.
–Yeah.
–I mean, we know
–Is that weird?
No, not really.
Because
you know, most of the time,
like internationally,
we're wearing Stars and Stripes, right?
So there's only two of us.
So the chance of us going head to head
is pretty likely.
Yeah, but still
It’s weird,
but no, I mean, I think we can,
we can kind of put it past us.
And we know when we step up
on the block, it's business.
It's competition, like,
it’s not like we don't like you,
we just want to beat the hell out of you.
What about the kids, though?
How are they with the water?
They love it.
They all absolutely love it.
Boomer is, Boomer swims
butterfly and freestyle.
Beckett goes underwater.
And he's like our little dolphin.
Boomer's five now, right?
–Yeah.
I can't wait till he...
I'm trying to think, like,
when will Boomer realize,
like,
who you are?
You know what I mean?
Like, I'm sure he knows
about the water or whatnot,
but he doesn't really know yet, right?
He calls me Aquaman.
Like, they all call me Aquaman,
but no, I don't,
I don't think he fully gets it yet. And he,
he'll always say, he's like,
“Can you beat that person?”
I'll be like,
“Look, back in the day, yes.
Not anymore, though.”
Man, this looks nice.
Feels so much better in the sun.
–Oh my gosh.
Good roll.
Dang,
you must live here or something.
Shhhh
A question that I always
wonder is if you didn't swim,
what would you do?
If I could choose anything,
I would want to be a golfer
just because I'm obsessed with the game.
We do that all the time.
But in reality, if I had to choose a sport
that I was good at,
I was a decent, decent baseball player.
Growing up, I played catcher.
I was always throwing the mask off,
so I was breaking the mask all the time.
Baseball players get paid.
They do, uh
Salary cap
Or a lacrosse player.
That's the other thing.
–Lacrosse?
I grew up on the East Coast,
so I played lacrosse
Oh, man.
So, yeah, I was a long stick middie
and, um, and then when I was 11,
my coach just basically said,
no more and focus on swimming
So, um,
what's next?
Besides me hopefully making this putt?
I mean, my biggest thing now is
all really around mental health.
I want to,
I want to try and lower the suicide number
as much as I can.
There are too many people
that are taking their own lives,
and I want to help
the people that are out there suffering.
When you get a chance to hear somebody say
that you changed and impact their lives,
that's, that's probably even more gratifying
than a gold medal now.
It's the best feeling in the world.
For me, being able to have
people share their experiences,
their moments, what they've been through,
showing their vulnerability.
Oh, my gosh, dude.
It, you can't put it into words.
It's the greatest feeling.
The one thing I can say is
I encourage every single person out there
to communicate, to open up,
to talk, don't stuff things down, don't
compartmentalize, because that stuff just
piles up, piles up on top of each other.
And before you know it,
it all just explodes.
That’s real.
I say that from firsthand because I know,
I was really good at compartmentalizing
throughout my career,
and I can't do that anymore.
That's real.
Well.
Oh, man.
Appreciate you.
For sure.
For real.
Always. Definitely.
Thank you.